[Music]
Dance Moms is one of those shows you
just can't stop watching for what
happened to the show's biggest stars
today we'll fill you in on some of the X
Dance Moms cast members and check out
what they're doing today stay tuned to
find out which cast member became the
biggest meme of Twitter if you like
crafts and DIY projects make sure to
check out our friends at crafty hackers
they will show you how to turn your
useless everyday items into amazing kid
toys their channel can be found in the
corner of our video but now it's time
for Dance Moms Brooke and Paige Hyland
let's talk about the oh geez for a
moment because let's be honest Dance
Moms would be a totally different show
without Brooke Paige and their mom Kelly
Brooke and Paige left the show in the
middle of season 4 after quite an
explosive argument with their dance
teacher the argument turned into
multiple lawsuits and eventually it
looks like everyone was slowly ready to
move on these days Brooke and Paige seem
to be leading a regular life as they go
to school and hang out with their
friends but in 2015 their mom confirmed
that both girls actually still dance but
aren't confined to a single dance studio
which most likely just means they aren't
doing competitions and are attending
drop in classes whenever needed Paige
admitted that she'd love to become a
dance teacher one day as she still loves
to dance and loves kids
but it looks like the Highland are
pretty happy to be finally doing regular
everyday activities and we can't really
blame them can we Paige also still
sometimes hangs out with her dance mom's
BFF Chloe and it's always fun seeing
them having a blast together after all
the gang's all there isn't it give this
video a thumbs up if you understood this
reference
brenn from follow but let's switch it up
and check out one of the late comers to
the dance moms world but despite being a
late comer Brynn became a pretty
memorable cast member Brynn quickly
gained a large fan base after appearing
in season 5 episode 8 for the first time
brenn was a beloved dancer with a
fantastic technique but the mama drama
never seemed to end between her her mom
Ashley Kendall and
both mom Jill after several tears and
plenty of screaming the elite team
finally disbanded in season seven
episode 25 and with that the Dance Moms
path was over for brynne our editor
pointed out that the show might not have
been the best thing that happened to
Brynn it put the normally very technical
and beautiful dancer through far too
many challenges that aren't normal even
in the professional dancing world their
editor also pointed out that weeks after
weeks you could see how filming took a
toll on her spirit but it seems that
this spirit is finally back now that
Dance Moms is over friend continued to
dance she appeared on numerous social
media videos as well as plenty of dance
and cheer competitions in July 2018 Fran
also opened up about being bullied
online by an adult woman who posed under
a Dance Moms fan accounts she was using
to make money
Nia sue Nia has been keeping busy since
Dance Moms she's already been making
moves while on the show and it only grew
stronger Nia actually remained the only
og cast member on the show that stayed
for the duration of seven seasons and
she definitely has the thick skin to
show for it
being on Dance Moms taught this little
diva how to be obviously resilient and
she's determined to not give up when it
comes to her dreams
Nia continued to pursue her passion in
music and performing in 2016 Nia
announced her first role on Broadway as
a character in a dance show called trip
of love in 2017 she appeared on the
irreplaceable store alongside her fellow
elite team Dance Moms members that left
the tour for unknown reasons
in the meantime Nia has become a huge
social media star with more than 4.5
million followers in 2018 she appeared
on the bold and the beautiful soap opera
TMZ reported that an appearance on a
single episode of the show earns her
2,500 per episode not bad for someone
who started her career on a dance
reality TV show right
Kalani Hilliker
after Dance Moms Kalani became busy in
2016 she announced a solo tour around
the UK with angel dance where you could
also see her in several viral dance
videos taken by la dance teachers during
their class she also launched her very
own line of socks in 2017 Kalani went on
the irreplaceable store around the world
with her fellow cast members Nia Kendall
and Chloe she also created a fashion
line and appeared in the 2017 New York
Fashion Week but 2018 appears to be the
busiest year for Kalani yet according to
her IMDB page Kalani has had plenty of
acting work under her belt she appeared
in a teen TV series called dirt where
she played a character called Sabrina
she was also a character in a dance
movie called Breaking Brooklyn which
will be released in 2019 furthermore she
completed her work for a movie called
swipes where she plays a character
called Ashley and as of August 2018 she
is also listed as a cast member for a
movie called adrenochrome 2 which is
currently in production
looks like Kalani has had a busy year
but she's definitely not stopping
anytime soon
the sky is the limit Kendall vertes if
you're a hardcore Dance Moms fan the
words it's Kendall's week might make you
giggle but truth be told kendall has
indeed had plenty of weeks that were
full of victories after she left Dance
Moms just like the rest of her elite
team member crew she went on the
irreplaceable tour and travelled the
world in 2016 she also released her own
emoji app called kimochi and we all know
she fired Abby Lee as her manager while
still on the show so what happened to
her music career in 2017 she released a
song called where would I be without you
and an adorable video featuring her
Dance Moms co-stars in December she
released a Christmas EP called camus
which featured two covers and three
original songs she also landed some
sweet modeling opportunities which
included a gig for fenty ex Puma as of
August 2018 her IMDB page also shows
that she's a cast member for a live
action movie and Nastasia currently in
post-production it's not yet clear where
she will go in terms of her music career
in 2018 but we're very excited to see
what this triple threat will do
next Eliana bonsly nobody knew what to
expect when Abby Lee announced that she
was making a brand new team full of many
dancers and it was even more confusing
because almost everyone's name ended
with Anna
but one person definitely stood out from
the rest Eliana is a talented dancer who
became a part of the main cast when she
was just 10 years old as the show ended
Eliana can still be found dancing at
various competitions she also appeared
in several 10-minute challenge videos
taken by the popular dance photographer
Jordan matter but that's not all it
looks like in August 2018 Dancing with
the Stars jr. shared a behind-the-scenes
photo of Ileana and some other talented
kid dancers let's be honest any dance
show is better with Eliana in it Eliana
could also be seen at Abby Lee Miller's
side as her former dance teacher battles
cancer in the hospital it's absolutely
heartwarming that this little kid is so
busy but yet makes the time to show love
and give positive vibes to those that
taught her a lot about the dance world
Chloe look hey Zack
Chloe was a beloved dancer and
everyone's hearts got collectively
broken when she left in season 4 we've
already pointed out a lot of things that
were wrong in this show in one of our
other videos but let's be honest
Abby's treatment of Chloe was one of the
most uncomfortable things about this
show but Chloe has been doing extremely
well for herself since she left the show
we all know she also came back in season
7 and attended to the irreplaceable
store but so much has happened in
between in 2016 Chloe appeared in center
stage on points where she played Gwyn
Murphy 2017 was also a big year for her
in terms of acting she worked on 4
separate movie projects and proceeded
acting in 2018 she is also credited as a
co-executive producer in a movie called
fr EDI in 2018 she also released her
very own book and even launched a book
club to encourage kids to read although
it's obvious that Chloe still dances it
looks like she's definitely taking a lot
of interest in plenty of other career
paths in the entertainment industry and
you know as they say the sky is the
limit
McKenzie Ziegler we all remember little
Mackenzie from her colorful statements
on the show like the time she said she
just wants to stay at home and eat chips
and
really go on dance competitions but
since then McKenzie has become a teenage
inspiration along with having a pretty
successful music career McKenzie created
her very own turn board which helps
dancers with their turns we've also seen
her in plenty of viral hip hop dance
videos where she dances alongside her
teacher Rumer Noel in 2018 makenzie also
went on a dance tour with her sister
Maddy where she showed she definitely
still has what it takes to be on dance
competitions McKenzie has also been busy
being a popular influencer on the
lip-sync app called musically as of
August 2018 she has an impressive 11
million followers on her Instagram these
days you can find her performing her
songs with her fellow music Johnny
Orlando although it seemed that everyone
wanted makenzie to follow in Maddie's
footsteps it looks like she was able to
create a path of her own way to go candy
make sure you comment down below and
tell us what your favorite Kenzie song
Maddie Ziegler how could we possibly
forget about the one and only Maddie
Ziegler arguably the star of the show
maddie officially left Dance Moms in
season 6 episode 8 team since then she
appeared in numerous SIA music videos
and spent a lot of time dancing
alongside SIA on her tour in 2016 Maddie
also launched her very own fashion line
which was one of the many business moves
this young superstar has made at 14 she
also got cast as a judge on So You Think
You Can Dance alongside Paula Abdul in
2017 she released a memoir titled
the Maddie Diaries which became the New
York Times best seller and if that
wasn't enough she also landed a role in
movies like ballerina and the book of
Henry it looks like this business savvy
team isn't stopping anytime soon as of
2018 she landed a commercial deal with
Tiffany & Co and she continues to appear
at various fashion dance and
entertainment events despite all her
adventures Maddie's still a dancer
Burghardt who practices for hours and
hours every single day until she
perfects her moves but she's not the
only person that's doing well for
herself
this next Dance Moms star only had a few
hundred Instagram followers when she
joined to the show in season 5 episode 3
but since then she became quite a
character
Jodeci WA if you spend a lot of time on
Twitter these days you probably noticed
that Jojo C hua seems to be known a lot
more than some
the other Dance Moms stars this power
dancer started her career on Dance Moms
with a lot of sass
and even more hair bows combined with
her moves full of attitude she quickly
became a popular character she
unexpectedly left the show at the end of
season six and although there were many
rumors floating around her exit was
never really properly explained but
since then
JoJo's definitely been making moves with
her incredibly successful YouTube
channel with over seven million
subscribers she also released a bow
collection at a popular retailer called
Claire's and collaborated with YouTube
superstars such as Miranda sings in 2018
Twitter started taking notice of JoJo's
personality and she immediately became a
meme people couldn't believe how tall
she is did you know she's five nine
seriously Twitter can't get over this
height but regardless
Jojo is definitely one of the most
talked-about Dance Moms members of 2018
and we have a feeling she'll continue to
be well after that and if that's not yet
impressive
Jojo also signed an overall talent deal
with Nickelodeon meaning you'll be
seeing this Dance Moms star even more
and that's it for our video thanks for
watching
see you next time
[Music]